WOJTEK KALICINSKI: I love
well-optimized apps, especially
apps with small APK size, which
makes downloads and updates
faster for users.
That's why I was
very excited when
a new tool for
analyzing APK issues
was added in Android Studio.
It's called the APK Analyzer,
and you can launch it
by clicking Analyze
APK in the Build menu,
or by dragging an
APK into the editor.
These can be files
built from your project,
or even APKs that you
don't have the sources for.
When selecting an APK file, make
sure you open a release build
or a debug build without
Instant Run instrumentation,
which you can obtain by going
through Build, Build APK.
You can check if an APK contains
Instant Run instrumentation
by confirming the presence
of an Instant Run zip
file in the archive.
Now let's go through the
main screen of the analyzer.
On the top here, you can
see some basic information
about your app, such as the
package name and version,
along with the raw APK size
and an estimated download size.
This may be smaller, thanks to
compression applied by the Play
Store in transit.
Below, you can see a
list of files and folders
in the APK, sorted in descending
order according to size.
This is extremely
useful when you're
trying to track down low-hanging
fruit for optimizing your app
size, such as
unoptimized drawables
or uncompressed audio files.
You can also see the
relative percentage
of total download size
of each asset or folder
in the rightmost column.
The APK Analyzer also
has a detail view that's
used for showing file contents.
It works with several
types of files.
You can preview XML
resources, such as layouts,
in their original,
human-readable form.
This also includes
the Android manifests,
so you can check out
exactly what values were
used when building the app.
You can also browse
the full resource
table that was compiled into
the resources.arsc file.
This contains a list
of strings and styles
for all resource configurations
defined in the app.
And finally, the analyzer
contains a dex file browser,
letting you inspect packages,
classes, and method signatures
to check for any errors
resulting from using ProGuard
or MultiDex.
And speaking of
MultiDex, every dex file
also shows a handy
reference counter
that tells you how close you
are to the 64k limit per file.
The APK Analyzer
is a great source
of actionable
information when trying
to decide where to start
optimizing your app size.
And after you make
your changes, you
can compare the new
version of your APK
with a previous one using
the Compare With action.
So you can check how
much space you gain
and if there are
any regressions.
I strongly recommend you
check out our article
on reducing APK size on
developersandroid.com,
and give the analyzer a spin.
Thanks, for watching.
And if you want to
learn more about Android
Studio and Android development,
click on one of the videos
here.
[MUSIC PLAYING]